well you can always find some good on
christmas of course catholic charities
welcome welcoming and neighbors on this
holiday our victoria saha was there
she's here now with a look at that
turnout victoria
hey david the holidays are tough for
people who don't have much but on a day
like today the catholic charities opened
their doors for anyone in need of a
traditional holiday meal
line started to form outside catholic
charities well before the 10 a.m meal
time giving you a small glimpse of just
how this event is cherished by the
community i'm very grateful just the
shelter the food that
they provide for the people that are
misfortunate you could say
or not in their best luck on the menu
roast beef mashed potatoes and a yule
cake the non-profit is doing their best
to make sure everyone receiving a meal
feels a sense of the christmas spirit
the suffering has not gone away i mean
obviously we're going through the
pandemic as a
as a world
but this population is just growing
we've seen a lot more people suffering a
lot more familiar faces that are coming
vicki joyner is one of those regulars
i've been here four months now and i eat
here regularly though times are tough
she says she never lost her christmas
spirit life is about giving you never
know what's going to happen tomorrow one
thousand meals were prepared with 40
volunteers prep time started well before
3 a.m
organizers with catholic charities say
events like this allow members of the
community to trust the organization to
help them with other resources they may
need in the studio victoria saha live
local now